hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
spring 2015 edition in this edition are
articles on generating and supporting
tourism in the district more money for
flood maintenance works details of the
may elections hockley art exhibition and
trail and free home safety checks and
much more but the first item is about
some very good news about funding for
local voluntary groups 100,000 pounds
funding for voluntary groups rochford
district council is providing more than
100,000 pounds in funding to support
local voluntary sector groups the cash
will help 20 organizations which benefit
the local community in a variety of
different ways including the provision
of activities for young people older
people carers and those with
disabilities this year the Rockford and
Rayleigh Citizens Advice Bureau has been
allocated 67,000 pounds and rarely
Rochford a district association for
voluntary service allocated 15,000
pounds summary chief executive of
Rochford and rayleigh CA be said this
funding will enable us to continue
providing a quality assured free
confidential independent and impartial
advice service in the district to all on
subjects including benefits debt housing
employment and relationship issues we
are grateful for the support of Rochford
District Council the local community and
our volunteers which makes a real
difference to people in the community
projects to receive capital funding
rayleigh age concern towards the
purchase of a new boiler fairview
under-fives a preschool in rayleigh
towards the cost of a storage shed fifth
rayleigh scout group towards the cost of
a new trailer Crouch Valley District
Scout Council to refurbish external
toilet and washing facilities first
rayleigh scout and cup group to replace
Assad cloths and waterproof five
Icelandic tents
Rankin's Cricket Club to purchase a new
site screen first hawk will scout group
towards the cost of rewiring the Scout
hat and to add extra lighting fourth
Rochford scout group towards the cost of
a scout hall extension stanbridge
Memorial Hall to purchase equipment for
disability sports project where
participants have been able to try their
hand at Sitting Volleyball bacha and
table cricket the funding will also help
other vital organizations run their
day-to-day services these are the
peaceful place great wakering summer
place team supporting carers and
families together dial basildon and
south essex basildon women's aid barling
magnet evergreens active Rochford south
end achievement through football
hopefully and Hawk called 55-plus centre
and just over 7,000 pound was left
unallocated from the capital funding pot
and was due to be opened up for
applications in the new year wildwoods
day plans are gearing up for the 12th
annual wild woods day which this year
takes place on a Saturday May the 30th
at hockey woods this year's event is set
to be the biggest yet with a host of new
activities experiences and entertaining
in the planning visitors will have the
chance to explore different zones
including a learning zone kids zone
green zone active zone and creative zone
an expanded marketplace and picnic area
plus an entertainment stage with South
in radio sees this popular event
continuing to grow each year hopefully a
cinema coming to town with summer on the
way Rochford district council is
inviting residents to grab a blanket
pack up some snacks and head outside to
see some classic movies in the open air
as some of the most impressive
surroundings in the district these
evening events hosted by essex outdoor
cinema are a first for the district and
will incorporate pre film entertainment
a bar and food outlets showings are sure
to be popular so choose from the list
i'm about to give you and book your
tickets quickly so what's coming up
shake
spearing love on Saturday June the sex
in hockley woods the age rating for that
is 15 to be confirmed you decide on
sunday june the seventh in hockley woods
residents will be invited to choose
which film should be shown just visit w
WX outdoor cinema calm and get voting
and on Saturday August the 15th is
grease in Swain park and this is a
parental guidance rating for more
up-to-date information and to book
tickets visit w wh 0 cinema com also
visit the website to vote for which film
we show on sunday june the seventh
tickets are all showings a 12-pound and
the gates open at seven pm please know
that open air cinema venues are subject
to capacity restrictions an entrance
without a pre booked ticket is not
guaranteed please pre booked your ticket
and arrive early to avoid disappointment
running or walking you decide after
months of planning and hard work by a
dedicated group of volunteers parkrun
has finally come to the district the
first hockley woods park run was held on
februari their seventh with 221 people
of all ages and abilities in attendance
there were first time Park runners
through two parkrun tourists who try to
visit as many different venues as they
can across the country everyone who took
part agreed that the historic woodlands
of Hollywood's provided a wonderful
backdrop for the latest addition to the
park run family hockley was parkrun
takes place every saturday at 9am in
hockley woods if you haven't registered
for parkrun please do so before
attending at ww parkrun or guk forward
slash hockley woods or why not sign up
for the Rochford district health walks
and castlepoint walk tall which have
just been officially recognized by
walking for health and awarded national
accreditation for their local walking
scheme the accreditation endorses the
quality of experience and support that
Walker's can expect when taking part in
the walks so the local weekly walks
include on a Monday Richmond hall
benfleet 1038
and holdrege 1045 a.m. wednesdays canvey
island sea wall meets in love with car
park at 1030am thursdays the main
entrance hockley woods at 1045 a.m. and
a walk takes place in hadley on the
first and third fridays of each month
meet in castle lane car park at the
bottom of castle lane at 1030am the
river crouch celebrations Roger District
Council's arts team an international
outdoor arts company kinetica present a
unique celebration which focuses on the
river crouch and local communities
living on the north and south banks the
event will celebrate this unique area of
essex over the next few years and
eventually lead into an annual river
festival plans for 2015 include arts
projects in schools and villages a
100-mile public walk and a final
celebratory event in hullbridge on
saturday july the 4th find the project
on facebook at WWF facebook.com forward
slash river crouch festival or on
twitter at at crotch riverfest
generating and supporting tourism in the
district rochford district council is
working with its partners to promote
tourism in the local area together we'll
be developing a strategy designed to
attract more visitors and to boost the
local economy rochford district is a
place that has many assets a diverse
environment spaces of unspoilt
attractive countryside and a rich
heritage including many iconic and
historic buildings the RSP bees wallasey
wild coast project which is set to
create europe's largest intertidal
habitat will attract an array of rare
birds and become an important new
visitor attraction this and other local
initiatives will be coming forward in
the near future and it's important that
we make the most of what we have to
offer and encourage all to get involved
rochford District Council has invested
in membership with visit Essex and you
can go to our webpage for this
one of our biggest and best assets is
the 65 square miles of predominantly
rural landscape with miles of unspoiled
coastline and attractive countryside
perfect for walking via our many
footpaths and public rights-of-way each
of the parish and town councils have
maps of their footpaths and public
rights-of-way and can be contacted for
more details you can call rochford
district council on 0170 2546 366 for a
list of useful websites for walkers
visit essex offers free help to
fledgling tourism businesses the council
is working with visit essex to establish
a program to help support and mentor
small business startups in the tourism
and hospitality industries for example
restaurants cafes visitor attractions
accommodation or activity providers if
you're a small business in the tourism
or related sector and have been in
business for less than 18 months or are
looking to set up a business in 2015
visit essex would like to support you by
offering free training in marketing and
customer care and a free mentoring
session you will also be provided with a
tourism toolkit if you are interested in
taking up this opportunity please email
Tracy Parker at Tracy Parker to and
that's the number two at Essex gov dot
uk' Rochford district photographic
competition spring 2015 we're looking
for photos that really portray the
rockford district at springtime the
photographs should be based on a spring
theme but could be of a place person pet
object or stunning view within the
Rockford district which ever you feel
depicts the district at its best at
springtime the photographic competition
will be judged by the chairman of the
council counselor mrs. June Lumley with
the images to be used in the promotion
of the district the best photos will
feature in the summer edition of
Rochford district matter
the council's quarterly news publication
with full credits in addition the best
images will also be displayed during a
future exhibition at Raley windmill
submitting your photos the competition
closes on April the 24th 2015 so please
ensure that you submit your photos by
that date at the council's website and
that's WWE our govt UK / spring photo
electronic images should be JPEGs and no
larger than 5 megabytes for all entries
please complete the competition form
clearly stating your name date of birth
contact details the location or subject
matter along with a brief reason why the
photo represents the Rochford district
for you please note that only one
photograph per person is permitted and
there are prizes for those over 18 years
of age the first prize is a 50 pounds
amazon voucher second prize 25 pounds
voucher third prize 15 pounds voucher
and for those under 18 years of age
first prize is 25 pound rapture second
prize 15 pound router and third prize 10
pound voucher terms and conditions apply
if you are under 18 years of age you
will need parent or guardian
authorization 20,000 pounds more for
flood maintenance works rochford
district council has allocated an
additional twenty thousand pounds to
flood maintenance works as part of an
ongoing drive to resolve flooding issues
for residents the decision was made at a
meeting of the forum for surface water
issues where the money was allocated
following a vote although rocks for
District Council is not responsible for
flooding issues it created the forum in
order to bring together organisations
including essex highways anglian water
the environment agency and the essex
county council flood management team to
find practical solutions for local
residents who have suffered from surface
water issues as a result of wet weather
the aim of the group is to find out who
is responsible for various watercourses
ditches and drains and then try to
ensure that those responsibilities are
complied with prior to the meeting
rochford District Council's principal
engineer visited various sites where
flooding has occurred to try to identify
the source of the problem and speak with
some of the affected residents before
passing his findings on to the relevant
agency to resolve these were then
discussed at the Forum meetings where
residents had the opportunity to raise
concerns about problem areas a motion
was made to spend eleven thousand pound
for warith Brook at fair maid and Boston
Avenue both in the rayleigh area and a
further 9,000 pounds for work at Noble's
green ditch at Bramfield road east and
Milt's and close again in the rayleigh
area this was put to a vote and agreed
rochford district council is eligible
for up to 50,000 pounds of match funding
from Essex County Council to tackle the
surface water flooding issues so
projects such as these can be supported
the council has already allocated funds
to dig a new ditch to the rear of blower
closed in rayleigh several other areas
have also had works completed help to
access funding rotifer district council
has helped families and businesses
affected by flooding to access
government funding there was the last
minute extension to the qualification
period for the flood support scheme by
the government meaning residents and
businesses who were flooded in august
2013 were eligible to seek financial
assistance to protect their properties
the council was able to help a number of
people to access these funds your
council tax explained rochford District
Council has decided to freeze its
portion of the council tax after
carefully considering the financial
impact of freezing the district counts
that is pleased to announce that its
share of the overall council tax bill
will remain at two hundred and eight
pound and ninety eight pence for an
average bandi property essex county
council and essex for authority have
frozen their parts of the overall tax
bill as well whilst
six police authority raised their
proportion by one point ninety-nine
percent this means that the total
average council tax bill for AB and E
property will be 1549 pound of 31 p per
annum an overall average increase of
three pound and 11 p / annum or point
two percent of your total council tax
bill only thirteen percent comes to
Rochford District Council with the rest
going to Essex County Council's seventy
percent Essex Fire Authority four
percent police and crime Commissioner
for Essex ten percent and the parish and
town councils three percent and here is
a comparison table for the proposed
council tax charge on a band d property
and i'll give you the 2014-15 figure
first then 2015 16 and then the increase
Essex County Council 1086 pound and 75 p
1086 pound and 75 piece are no increase
police and crime Commissioner for Essex
144 pound p and 147 pound 15 p one point
nine nine percent rot your district
council 208 pound and 98 pins 208 pound
and ninety eight pence so no increase
their Essex Fire Authority 66 pound 42
and sixty-six pound 42 and no increase
their parish councils 39 pound 78p 40
pound and 1p and the increase there is
point five eight percent so the total
1546 pound 20 p 1549 / and 31p so an
increase of 0.2% budget consultation
these areas were identified as the most
important services in the council's
recent budget consultation recycling
street scene and community safety the
lowest priority areas were rayleigh
windmill leisures premises and economic
development residents were also asked
for the top issues that they think the
council should deal with
these included Community Safety flooding
recycling and litter and fly tipping the
budget survey asking residents to
prioritize council services was
published in the last edition of
Rochford district matters and made
available online on the council website
this was publicized via local media and
social media copies of the survey were
also available at local libraries and
distributed at council meetings and
Rochford market in order to get as many
responses as possible the council
received a total of two hundred and
eighty four responses 102 by post and
182 online the feedback from this
consultation was considered by
councillors during the budget process if
you answered the budget survey or if you
want to help shape and inform policy in
the future why not join our have your
say group the group is made up of
Rochford district residents who
volunteer to express their views on the
council's proposals and local services
the information you provide helps the
council to make its decisions in order
for us to get the information we need
you will be asked to fill in
questionnaires and participate in focus
groups when signing up you'll be asked
to highlight any particular areas of
interest to ensure your views are taken
into account when relevant consultations
come up you can sign up for the group at
wwt a govt UK / h ys sign up or you can
phone the community planning office on
0170 231 8061 or email community
planning at Rochford gavotte UK do you
want to be involved in how local money
is spent in the NHS NHS castle point and
Rochford ccg are looking for local
residents to represent Railly and
Rochford localities for more information
contact see Ralph that's
er 0 uth at NHS net or call 0126 859 for
419 7,000 jobs to land in the district a
plan to generate thousands of jobs
across to new business parks near london
Southend Airport is set to become a
reality the proposals known formally as
the london Southend Airport and environs
joint area action plan will see upward
of a hundred million pounds of
private-sector investment in the area
over the next 10 to 15 years they have
now been adopted at four council
meetings of Southend Borough Council and
Rochford district council the plans
envisage 7,000 jobs being created within
the next 15 years through the
construction of up to 100,000 square
meters of new employment space as well
as developing the skills of young people
locally and opening the way for
apprentice apprenticeships these players
will also save a lot of out commuting
and this combined with the Associated
highway network in particular the a127
will take pressure off our roads these
new business parks next to an
international airport and with excellent
access to the mainline railway into
London will help us to attract further
investment and create much-needed jobs
for the area key features of the
proposals include a site for the anglia
ruskin med tech campus which will
deliver space and support businesses in
the medical technologies sector an
innovation center providing flexible
commercial accommodation for
entrepreneurs and small businesses up to
100,000 square metres of new employment
space including good quality new office
space a further 15,000 square meters of
employment space to be made available
for redevelopment on the existing
aviation way industrial estate new
opportunities for aviation related
maintenance and overhaul businesses to
develop on the extension of the northern
maintenance repair and overhaul area of
the airport new attractive public open
spaces and landscaping and investment in
sporting facilities
is transport improvements within the
joint area action plan and on the local
and wider networks including new routes
and junction improvements a junction on
Cherry Orchard way to improve access to
the country park and create an access
point for the business park local
businesses are being given a helping
hand thanks to a 50,000 pound funding
pot Roger District Council has been
distributing grants to businesses to
support them to grow while creating and
safeguarding jobs across the district
the scheme has been overseen by the
council's economic development team who
obtained the funding from the business
South End growth hub these businesses
have been awarded grants Eva UK limited
is using the grant of 10,000 pound to
expand by repairing and refurbishing
their showroom this will safeguard 29
jobs and create up to six new jobs jks
group limited is a haulage company that
also specializes in earthworks aggregate
and recycling their 10,000 pound grant
will help expand their workshop facility
and will increase their fleet by another
10 vehicles creating 12 new jobs Pemex
limited is a limited company that
provides energy sustainability and
utilities consultancy and will refurbish
and expand into the office area next
door using their grant of 2329 pound
this will allow for planned expansion
creating for jobs and safeguarding 10
jobs practical HR is an HR consultancy
service based in Great Wakering they
receive 6690 pound enabling an office
refit and the creation of to new posts
the mega center is a not-for-profit
social enterprise based in rayleigh and
received ten thousand pound for new air
conditioning units enabling 20 jobs to
be safeguarded and one job to be created
the day nursery's 4277 pound grant will
enable them to have a better equipped
fit for purpose site it will safeguard
20 jobs while creating for new posts the
mole bruh head pub received a 5000 to
and an eight-pound grant to upgrade
working areas and purchase new kitching
equipment this will safeguard for jobs
and create two new posts rochford
District Council's economic development
team has scooped the high impact award
for helping local startup businesses
they achieve this by taking part in the
globe Global Entrepreneurship Week where
they worked in partnership with Pro
actions and NW es to offer workshops on
how to create and successfully grow a
startup businesses or young small
business the team has also been running
successful business summits which enable
attendees to find out about business
opportunity and take part in workshops
specially tailored to meet their needs
planning a key document to ensure that
development coming forward in the
district is appropriately managed will
remain in place after the high court
rejected a challenge by a member of the
public who was seeking to quash it the
challenge was against the allocations
planned document which was put in place
to prevent a free-for-all for developers
who wanted to build in the district the
plan conforms to the framework set out
in the Rockford core strategy 2011 and
allocates specific sites in the general
locations set out in the core strategy
for a range of uses including housing
and employment development as well as
providing protection for sensitive areas
including the upper roch valley a member
of the public launched a legal challenge
against the adoption of the allocations
plan earlier this year the claim
considered whether consultation on the
allocations plan had met the
requirements set out in both the
government's regulations and the
council's own statement of community
involvement the council's policy for
consultation beyond the minimum national
requirements the council received nearly
9,000 responses over the two stages of
the consultation on the allocations plan
and core strategy in addition to the
responses made to the Rockford core
strategy consultation events on the
allocations plan
included public meetings public
exhibitions manned and unmanned school
workshops newsletters leafletting and
mail shots as well as extensive use of
our online consultation system the
Honorable justice lindblom ruled that
the plan should remain in place without
amendments in his judgment he said in my
view in the light of the evidence before
the court the council did not breach any
of the requirements of section 19 part 3
and regulation 18 when preparing and
adopting the allocations plan it
complied with them all the inspectors
that's the inspector who was appointed
by the government to examine the plan
and found it sound conclusions to that
effect were not only reasonable they
were also I believe right the judgment
means that the allocations plan remains
in place in full and will continue to be
used to manage development proposals
coming forward in the district the full
document can be viewed at ww govt UK /
allocations if the allocations plan had
been quashed or deleted it would not
have meant no development in the
district but it would have led to a lack
of certainty as to where development
would go and how much they would be
deleting the allocations plan would also
have removed a number of requirements
for developers that protect the local
environment and residents quality of
life the use of greenbelt land we have
prioritized brownfield sites for
development where this is achievable but
these sites will not provide the number
of dwellings required to fully meet our
housing needs over the next 10 to 15
years that being the case it has been
necessary to allocate some land from the
Greenbelt for development in sustainable
locations the alternative would have
been to have had no plan in place to
manage development coming forward
risking a developer free for all day to
day planning rochford district council
has adopt
a plan to ensure the building of
appropriate sustainable development in
the future the development management
plan sets out the detailed day-to-day
policies by which planning applications
will be assessed the document was
approved at a full council meeting on
December the 16th and includes policies
for the design of new developments
housing extension limits in the
greenbelt and equestrian facilities this
plan which has previously been approved
by a government inspector will now sit
beneath the core strategy and alongside
the allocations plan the plan can be
viewed at wwh Fujio vu k /d NP the
allocations plan your questions answered
why were only thirty five percent of new
homes be affordable housing prior to the
adoption of the rocks for core strategy
the now revoked East of England regional
plan concluded that of the new homes to
be provided in the district thirty-five
percent should be affordable the council
appointed an independent consultant the
resultant report concluded that a target
of about thirty percent would be
appropriate however a further report
prepared in 2008 suggested that fifty
percent would be more appropriate based
on the analysis and taking into account
the East of England plan the Rockford
core strategy determined that a
35-percent figure was appropriate
reasonable and deliverable respondents
commented that the allocations plan will
have a negative impact on infrastructure
and roads in the area the assessment of
the impact of new development was
carefully considered during the
preparation of the Rockford core
strategy and the allocations plan
furthermore these concerns were examined
in detail by the independent inspector
who hold a public examination to
consider the objections and concerns
raised about both documents the council
will require all planning applications
submitted for development of allocated
sites to include suitable proposals for
the improvement and or provision of
infrastructure the principal
infrastructure improvements
right by the council for each allocated
site are shown in the site capacity and
concept statement sections of the
allocations document why choose
greenfield sites why not just use
brownfield the K also looked at all
opportunities to bring forward suitable
brownfield sites for development however
there are actually very few brownfield
sites and the total amount of
development required means that a modest
release of land from the Greenbelt for
development was necessary it is also
relevant to note that it is a statutory
requirement set out by government that
the council must seek to meet its
objectively assessed housing need a
present this figure is 250 new dwellings
per year until 2025 respondents stated
that many of the allocated sites were
located on the floodplain and asked why
this was this is categorically not the
case and the misunderstanding perhaps
arises from a peculiarity in the weight
land is categorized in terms of the
likelihood of flooding occurring all
land is divided into flood zones and
these zones are called flood zones 1 2 &
3 these zones relate to the probability
of land flooding in fact despite the
terminology round categorized as flood
zone one is actually at least risk of
flooding and is considered to be where
housing development should always take
place unless there are compelling
reasons to develop in higher risk zones
all development on allocated sites in
the district will be on land that is
categorized as flood zone one with one
brownfield site exception the only
housing development site identified in
the allocations plan which is at risk of
flooding is Stanbridge Mills site b FR 3
which is a brownfield site however the
allocations plan only allows this site
to be developed for housing if adequate
flood improvement measures are put in
place alongside the site's redevelopment
it is correct to say that small parts of
several site allocations including land
in flood zones two and all three but
crucially no housing
will be developed in those areas which
will most likely be used to provide open
space or be incorporated into the
sustainable drainage system for the site
the main purpose of sustainable drainage
system known as suds is to mimic the
natural drainage of the site before
development this is achieved by
capturing rainfall and allowing as much
as possible to evaporate or soak into
the ground close to where it fell the
remainder is directed to the nearest
water course to be released at the same
rate and volume as before development
started the allocations plan requires
appropriate suds to be determined in
consultation with assets county council
the approval body for suds and the
Environment Agency the UNAC asians plan
also requires that a site-specific flood
risk assessment incorporating a surface
water drainage strategy should be
prepared for all sites if residents
subject to the plan then why should it
go ahead the submission of
representations to a plan is considered
to be an important way to inform and
shape the final plan however the council
is required by government to prepare a
development plan and part of the process
underpinning this is an assessment of
housing need the government says that
local authorities must prepare a plan
showing how the objectively assessed
housing needs will be met the Rochford
call strategy seeks to achieve this
through modest sustainable extensions to
the existing built-up parts of the
district whilst it is understood that
residents may express a broad view that
development should not take place this
is at odds with the government's demands
of local authorities furthermore if the
allocations plan was abandoned the
housing requirement will still have to
be met nope and would not mean no
development no plan would however mean a
lot less local control over where and
how much development would take place
and what infrastructure would be
required to be provided alongside
development further answers to your
questions can be found at WWF a govt UK
/a
patience q parliamentary and local
elections parliamentary of general
election on Thursday may the seventh
voters will go to the polls to elect
their member of parliament for the next
five years most Rochford District
Council residents are in the
constituency of Rayleigh and wickford
however those living in the wards of
bowling and sutton found s and great
wakering and Rochford fall under the
Rochford and south and east constituency
and will therefore be voting to elect a
different MP to those living in the
rayleigh and wickford constituency this
is because the parliamentary
constituency boundaries are different to
the district council areas district
elections rochford district council is
made up of 19 wards represented by 39
councillors a third of these seats or 13
of them are up for election if you live
in one of these wars you will also be
voting for your district councillor on
May the seventh ashington and knut
bowling and sutton down hall and rora
'the foul nurse and great wakering
grange hawk well north hawk or south
hawk or west hockley central hullbridge
lodge rochford and swain park parish
councils hold their elections every four
years and these parishes are also due to
have elections on may the seventh
ashington barley magna can you Dan
furness great wakering hawk well pagal
shem stanbridge and sutton if you're
unable to go to the polling station on
polling day you can apply for a postal
or proxy vote the closing date for new
postal votes offer changes to existing
postal or proxy arrangements for all
elections taking place on May the
seventh is 5 p.m. on tuesday the april
the 21st you can apply for a proxy vote
until five p.m. on tuesday april the
28th you can also phone us on 0 1 702
318 187 or email elections at Rochford
govt ok so a reminder of the last day to
register to vote is Monday April
twentieth to register for
you post or vote or change existing
postal approximate proxy arrangements is
5 p.m. on tuesday april the 21st to
apply for a proxy vote is 5 p.m. on
tuesday april the 28th and to return
your completed postal vote 10 p.m. on
thursday may the 7th on thursday may the
7th the polling stations are open from
7am to 10pm the election alarm clock is
the convenient way to keep up to date
with all the information regarding
upcoming elections by signing up to the
election alarm clock you will be alerted
to upcoming elections when and how to
register for elections when and how you
can vote and where you can vote to sign
up for this service visit www k /e
lection alarm clock and that is all one
word fill in your details as requested
and click Submit that's it once you've
done this you will start to receive
election alerts your vote matters make
sure you're in to vote in a UK election
you must be on the Electoral Register if
you have recently moved house you may
not be registered to vote at your new
address paying council tax does not
automatically register you to vote you
can register to vote online at www k /z
stir hyphen to hyphen vote registering
online takes about five minutes don't
miss out on the chance to have your say
and the deadline for registering to vote
for the may 2015 elections is Monday
April the 20th parks and woodlands
spring is here and the clocks have
sprung forward so why not take the
opportunity to venture out in the
district and see who else is making the
most of the spring sunshine the Rochford
district is the perfect place for this
with its rolling countryside beautiful
open spaces and woodlands where you can
see some of our more rare and cautious
wildlife who often find themselves far
too busy to worry about us birds sing
loud and clear
to mark territory and attract a mate why
not pay a visit to Swain Park to hear
them in song better heard and not seen
than seen and not heard grass snakes and
lizards are often slow to move during
the first few hours of sunlight try
exploring a sunny log pile in kendall
park hullbridge or the sea wall at
wallasey bejeweled butterflies and
insects emerge and bedazzle us with
their colorful displays hockley woods
and Magnolia Park are perfect for this
with their sheltered sunny paths and
glades the best times to catch a glimpse
of these beautiful creatures is between
11am and 2pm the heath fritillary
butterfly is very rare but can be
spotted at hollywood's young badger and
fox cubs will be taking their first
furry footsteps into the evening light
want to see them try visiting cherry
orchard jubilee country park or Millview
meadows keep low quiet and downwind the
following flowers can be spotted in most
of our woodland wood and M&E lesser
celandine dog violet Primrose the cherry
trees will also be in blossom always
respect wild spaces and Wildlife take
home your litter photos and memories and
leave only your footprints environment
where second for our recycling rates
rochford District Council has been named
as second in the entire country for its
recycling rates we would like to thank
our residents for all their recycling
efforts following the announcement from
the department for environment food and
rural affairs known as Defra which
monitors waste and recycling figures
statistics released by defra placed
Rochford second in the league with a
recycling rate of 65 point four seven
percent out of more than 350 local
authorities across england the district
has been in the top three for the past
four years and has topped the table on
two separate occasions this success has
been thanks to residents embracing the
simple three bins system
with one bin for non-recyclables one for
recyclables and one for compostables the
reliable collection service run by Sita
UK has also made it easier for residents
to use it's important to keep hitting
the recycling message home with a
dedicated recycling team which work
works hard to ensure residents are kept
informed their recent rethink rubbish
event was a huge success with more than
400 people flocking to the mill Arts &
Events Centre for a day of family fun
with an educational twist the event
marked the 10th anniversary of our first
curbside recycling scheme and included a
textile reuse fashion show a recycled
rhythms performance using rubbish to
make music and fabric and recycled art
workshops other initiatives have
included illuminating the rayleigh
windmill green using the ever-popular
max the dragon as the council's
recycling mascot and producing a
christmas recycling soul for youtube
this is in addition to visiting schools
and scout groups to ensure children are
learning the recycling message from an
early age which has involved giving
sewing lessons to encourage the reuse of
clothes making decorations from old
bottles and CDs and making fabric weaves
from old rags the team also provides
educational talks to community groups to
continue to spread the message about
which items can be recycled or reused
just when you thought you'd heard it all
our street scene team has launched
another new initiative to reduce dog
fouling in the district joining forces
with environmental charity keep britain
tidy they decided to tackle the issue
using social media and word of mouth the
initiative involves a YouTube video
featuring dogs from around the district
set to the famous song you to me are
everything with a few lyrical changes
the video has seen more than 3,400 hits
and is designed to raise awareness this
is all part of a renewed effort to
tackle dog fouling which has involved
placing we are watching you posters in
problem locations pavement stencils with
key messages and scoop my poop bandanas
dogs to see the video go to www k /to to
me rochford district councils street
scene team has been selected as a
finalist in the campaign of the year
award 2015 and environment award 2015
categories of the local government
Chronicle public service awards for its
charity bins project the pioneering
project was carried out by the council
with keep britain tidy and funded by
wrigley in each month of the pilot the
bins in rayleigh high street were
labeled with a sticker explaining that
one of three local charities would
benefit if people put their litter in
the bin the litter bend in each
charities month was weighed and compared
to the weight of the litter collected
from the street the results revealed a
dramatic reduction in litter levels in
rayleigh the pilot a first for the UK
incentivized people tube in their litter
responsibly by linking the amount of
litter collected in the bins to
donations to local charities this
resulted in the charities benefiting
from a total of 1331 pounds 50 which was
put towards their activity in the local
community in the Rochford district the
winners will be announced as a special
ceremony at Grosvenor House Hotel Park
Lane London out and about rayleigh
windmill reopened its doors to the
public on Saturday March the 28th it is
open wednesdays 10 a.m. to 1pm and
saturdays and sundays 1pm to 4pm until
the end of sep tember check w WR 0 govt
UK ford / windmill or follow us on
twitter at Raley underscore mill for
information about the latest events and
to check for changes to opening times
clumps and groups events at Rochford a
library are wishing well center every
tuesday 945 to 10 15 am stories and
rhymes for babies and toddlers job club
every Thursday to tea or 4pm get help
and advice with building
your CV and searching for work baby and
toddler group every Friday 9 30 to 10
a.m. stories and rhymes for babies 25
years old book sale every Saturday all
day dia el dial disability information
and advice last Tuesday of each month
1030am to 130pm caremark advice on care
and support at home last thursday of
each month ten a.m. to 12noon computer
training we can help you to start using
a computer just ask staff for details
activeview fun and friendly exercise
sessions with informal health talks
dance fit aerobics circuits Pilates and
more this is a free 12 week program and
it we're coming to you at various
locations for further information call
active life on Oh 17025 67 327 computer
advice for older people friendly advice
on using computers for older people this
is on the first thursday of each month
2pm to 4pm and there is no need to book
this is at the parish council rooms 82
West Street Rochford contact alan 0126
8780 738 for more details disability
sports free weekly sessions in baccio
table cricket and other sports this is
on Fridays 230 p.m. to 5pm at stanbridge
Memorial Hall and the sessions are free
of charge contact oh 1 702 2585 double 6
or a 7 8 7 6 8 0 2 420 memorial hall at
Stanbridge pc co uk or sport at Rochford
WK Rochford extended services weekly
family drop-in sessions these support
and advice families with children at
school in the Rochford district this is
on Wednesdays 930 a.m. to 1130am at the
annex since razors primary school in
ashington row rochford contact details
are 01
545 double 71 extension three double 26
and lastly Rochford hockey club this is
a friendly and sociable men's hockey
club looking for new players of any
ability training is on wednesdays at
eight pm and matches are played saturday
afternoons the venue is king edmund
school Rochford and the contact details
is 07 for double 570 407 1 and coming to
you this spring rayleigh bowls club
invites prospective bowlers to come to
their recruitment days to try their hand
at lawn bowls under the guidance of club
members it's on april the 25th to 26 and
may the second to the third 9am to 1pm
bring flat-soled shoes going to be held
at Raley Bowls Club King George the
fifth field in rayleigh you can contact
the club secretary Sheila McEvoy on 0 1
702 2 3 12 18 come to a hot clean
district horticultural societies trading
out for friendly advice on various
aspects of gardening and to purchase
compost grow bags and fertilizers at
very competitive prices it's open from
Sunday on tip from ten a.m. to 12noon
and it's behind hawk or village hall
membership is three pound per family per
year you can contact sylvia bird on 0 1
702 206 220 or bird's nest to at total
net rocks your parish council is
planning a made a fair in rochford
square on sunday made the third for
details contact Rochford Parish Council
on Oh 17025 4072 to the roach art group
is celebrating their 25th anniversary
with a spring exhibition an open day
it's on Saturday April the 25th from
11am to 3pm at Raley WI hall in
bellingham Lane Railly is free admission
contact John on 079 double 3263 930 or
depths on 07 9077 1400 to or their
website is w WH
art group dot WI XCOM forward slash
Roach hyphen art hyphen group Family
Theater this popular program of theatre
and puppetry at the mill arts & Events
Center in rayleigh is aimed at children
aged two to eight and their families the
shows are based on familiar stories as
well as original tales and including on
May seventeenth and a sunday 2 p.m. Red
Riding Hood by the Norwich puppet
theater sunday again June the 14th at
2pm the circus spectacular by Angel
Heart theater and on Sunday July the
12th at 2pm up in the attic by floods of
ink theater company tickets cost for
pound and are likely to sell out so
contact 0170 2318 1912 book oysters and
east angles Theatre Company production
featuring oral history interviews and
age-old traditions of oyster fishing and
boat building on the river colne in
Essex it's on Tuesday may the 19th at
seven-thirty it's at the Kate Spiller
theater in Swain Park School raley
because nine pound and is adults only
contact Oh 1473 to double 1498 or their
website WWE stern angles calm and
celebrate 50 years of choral singing in
rayleigh to mark their 50th anniversary
swain choral society will be performing
a garlic jubilee concert on Saturday May
the 16th at swaying Park School in
rayleigh under the direction of their
musical director Colin Edwards the choir
will perform Rutter's magnificent
Vivaldi's Gloria with soloists from the
Guildhall School of Music and Drama to
make the concert truly memorable the
quarry vites former singers to join them
rehearsals are held at Swain park school
on Monday evenings from 732 930 p.m. for
further information contact Oh 1268
double 70 69 80 1245 3 20 to 12 or visit
www Swain
choral society or one word Oh UK Council
and committee meetings Development
Committee April the 23rd Standards
Committee April the 9th review committee
April of 14th the executive April the
15th and full council April the 21st all
meetings will take place at the Civic
sweet to hockey road rayleigh SS 680 be
starting at seven thirty p.m. for
information call member services on 0170
2318 140 please note that although
events are checked before going to press
they are subject to change and we
recommend you visit our website or
contact the organisers to check before
going to an event and if you have an
event we can put it on our website so
visit www.flu.gov UK in the parishes
hockley art exhibition and art trail
2015 Hockley's first art trail in 2014
was a great success for artists traders
and residents following positive
feedback hockley parish council are
organizing another art trail in 2015 and
launching a new art exhibition the art
exhibition will be held over the weekend
of April the 18th and 19th at the old
fire station South End Road hockley and
will allow a number of local artists to
exhibit and possibly sell their artwork
many forms of art will be on display
including oil watercolor acrylic pestle
and pencil entry to the exhibition will
be free for the viewing public an event
program for giving details of artists
and their artwork will be available from
participating artists local shops and
hockley parish council office the art
trail will be held over three days
between july the second and fourth and
will be spread across approximately 30
venues in hockey town centre the trial
will showcase a variety of artwork by
local artists and art groups and is
likely to include paintings for
ography ceramics sculptures and jewelry
entry to this event will be free for the
viewing public an event program and
trail map providing details of artists
art forms and venues will be available
from participating exhibitors local
shops hockley library and hockley parish
council office further details of both
events can be obtained from counselors
Tim Glee doll 0 1 702 2016 double eight
Veronica Randall 0170 to 20 21 for two
or so Martin 0170 220 to 750 residents
of stanbridge led by the Parish Council
have worked together to restore their
invaluable village hall originally built
in 1905 for farmworkers to take their
breaks the hall became an important hub
for local people to congregate but sadly
over time the hall became dilapidated
and unusable thanks to a 20,000 pound
grant from the community initiative
foundation 7,000 pound from the Essex
Community Foundation 1500 pound from
Rochford district council plus capital
funding from stanbridge parish council
who are the sole trustees of the
memorial hall residents could work
together to restore their hoard to its
original beauty making it the heart of
the community once more stanbridge
memorial hall now houses many local
groups including mini marvels preschool
disability sport and the Stanbridge
fishery program and welcomes people and
groups from across the district to use
its facilities the First Parish summit
has been hosted by Rochford District
Council as part of efforts to work
together in the interests of residents
the event was organized by the council's
economic development team to encourage
better communication between the
district parish and town councils so
that we can work more closely together
it also provided a forum for councils to
learn from each other's experience to
the benefit of all those who live and
work in the district delegates heard
from guest speakers including Essex
Police RSPB and Rochford
council's planning and economic
development teams workshops included
communication and training emergency
planning Environmental Services
initiatives and funding local highways
neighborhood planning groups and tourism
visit your local market this spring with
a friendly bustling atmosphere and huge
variety of affordable goods on offer
it's well worth visiting your local
market this spring the district's weekly
markets feature a wide variety of stalls
including fruit and veg clothing and
household products Rockford mark pitts
meets every tuesday in rochford square
Raley market meets every Wednesday along
Raley high street and for something a
bit different rochford farmers market
meets on the first Saturday of every
month in the WI hall 930 a.m. till
midday selling quality local produce
rochford District Council has planted
trees at Cherry Orchard Jubilee country
park in remembrance of those who fought
in the First World War one of the many
commemoration events been organized
around the district the tree planting
was a unique and special opportunity to
leave a long lasting legacy of the brave
First World War servicemen 420 tree
saplings had been donated by the
Woodland Trust which have been planted
as an avenue to represent the location
of the key battles throughout the war on
this front after the saplings were
planted John Baker chair of
southend-on-sea branch of the Western
Front Association that a small ceremony
of remembrance which was followed by a
minute's silence mr. Baker said I would
like to thank the woodland trust and rot
your district council for supporting my
project to create a living memorial to
all those who served and died during the
First World War the tree-lined path has
been laid out in the shape of the
Western Front that stretched for over
450 miles from the Belgian coast to the
border with Switzerland each tree
represents a man from the borough who
died in the conflict and the two lines
of trees represent the opposing
frontline trenches as people walk along
the path I hope they will take time to
reflect on all those who
made the supreme sacrifice for their
country the council is also proud to
publish a record to remember the
sacrifice of more than 400 local men who
died in the First World War the list
details the name of each man unit or
ship in which he served date he died and
where he is buried or the memorial where
he is remembered it could be accessed at
wwh Fujio UK forward slash ww1 the list
was compiled as a personal project by
Rochford district council employee jim
Cavani who is a member of the Western
Front Association he had the sistance of
mike davis and john priestly are rarely
through the looking glass if you want to
try their website it's w WR le history
co uk fear irvin rot your district
community archive wwrd CA oo uu k Jon
Baker chairman of southend-on-sea branch
of the Western Front Association Caron
Dennis memorial officer Essex branch
Western Front Association Rochford
district councils community safety team
is looking for local businesses and
services that can assist in the relaunch
of their j9 campaign to stop domestic
abuse and help victims to seek the help
they so desperately need the j9 domestic
violence initiative is named in memory
of Jeanine Mundy who was killed by her
husband while he was on police bail each
business or service signed up as a j9
information point will display the j9
sticker in their window so victims know
where they can obtain information to
help them access the support they need
providing information and the use of a
phone in an emergency to sign up call
0170 2318 112 or visit w wh 0 govt UK /
j9 free home safety checks as part of
free home safety check officers from
trading standards and the fire service
visited residents homes to provide
advice around cold calling
eps selling and fire safety they were
joined by a qualified electrician who
carried out portable appliance testing
known as pat on a small domestic
appliances in order to prevent and
reduce accidental dwelling fires any
item that failed the pact test was fixed
or replaced free of charge which ensured
residents were not left without
essential appliances the community
safety team in partnership with Essex
County Council's Trading Standards will
be holding a series of free one-day home
safety checks throughout 2015 to be
eligible you must be aged over 65 years
or require additional support due to a
learning disability or mental physical
or sensory impairment if you meet the
criteria and would like to be included
please email community safety at
Rochford Gulf UK or telephone 0170 2 3
1810 3 cope events community older
persons events they will be held across
the district to give the older
generation lots of information on how to
stay safe in their daily lives these
will be on Wednesday April the 8th in
hockley first in June the 25th in Great
Wakering and Thursday October the first
in stanbridge free transportation
refreshments and lunch are also on offer
places must be booked in advance for
more information and to book please call
the community safety team on 0 1 702 3
1810 3 rochford district matters is
designed and published by Rochford
District Council the telephone number
for the council is 0 1 702 546 366 the
magazine is printed by Morton
print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4 5 6 and
this recording has been produced by
volunteers from the rayleigh Rochford
and castle point talking newspapers